the hall-of-fame coach Coach Knight
joining us
coach how are you this morning I'm doing
okay I was reminiscing about 1976 of
just how balanced that team was how were
they die rabbit I reminisce about that
every day really sure I like those kids
those kids were the best that ever
played what was it about them that made
it all work they it's like a jigsaw
puzzle that all fit together certainly
in that season they were really smart
those kids were smart and they they were
aggressive they really wanted to they
saw they had a chance to do something I
think it was kind of unusual and it's
obviously been unusual because nobody's
done it and you had leadership though
but you had guys who were you know that
back then everybody was staying for
years if that was today you wouldn't
been able to keep them probably for
longer than two years could you
conjecture you never know what that's
gonna be like I kids were really you
know how old were you that that season
so 41 years ago or 31 years ago I love
that plaid coat did you keep any of
those plaid jackets no I don't know
there's a fashion statement though coach
I've never really considered myself as
dealing with fashion when was the last
time you were with that seventy sixteen
well I just tried to call a couple
things in sports that are special and
this was something very very special the
key to it was about the year before we
had not gone undefeated I kind of
screwed things up Scott made it broken
his wrist and I had to move things
around a little bit and we ended up
losing a game and and I and part of it
was because I split Buckner and
Wilkerson up there the best pair guards
that ever played the game in college and
I've always said if I had one thing to
do over again I wouldn't have split that
up but anyhow we came to the next year
that and and and I told those kids on a
practice started on a Saturday is it
always did and that's all those kids a
day before practice started that there
was only one thing that would be the
thing that they could always be proud of
and that was to go undefeated for the
entire season not when the victor not
win the national championship or
anything but to go completely undefeated
for the season I told them that the day
before practice condoms at Friday
afternoon we met in the locker room I
said this is the gold and you people
should get to because there may be
nobody that ever does it but you are
capable of doing it and they wound up
doing this pretty good
UCLA did it a couple of times but I did
Michigan was a big rival back then in
1976 how so I'd rather that you told me
there coach don't think the best by
knowledge don't find it since those kids
who was the big rival back then whoever
we were playing but Michigan had a
really good team back then I remember
well I'm sure they that year I think we
had to be them twice well you played the
perfect half I think that the second
time you played them didn't you didn't
you score like 57 58 points in the
second half something like that you know
[Laughter]
I was wondering if you missed practice
more than you do the games well I just
really liked the game and that's why on
that on that Friday afternoon after the
year before that I forgot what our total
record was it was like 29 and 1 or 30
and 1 or something like that one when we
got beat and they got hurt but what I
did the day before practice started it
was on a Friday and I went through the
season and told them that the one thing
that they were capable of doing was
going not winning as I said not winning
the Big Ten or anything else but going
through the entire season undefeated and
and the Onaga these can you figure that
that that's two years and their record
with some
in like sixty two and one for those two
years he's Bob night the documentary is
perfect in 76 it airs tonight on
Showtime at 9:00 Eastern any surprises
in this documentary but they sat down
and talked to you well yeah you know I
told them what I thought I told them how
we went about where I told them that day
before the first practice and I think
they really I think it was an
interesting thing for those kids I mean
I think when they were told by their
were made injuries really really hurt
and and and I took the response for
splitting up Buckner and Wilkerson
mmm-hmm
and so we ended up we ended up getting
beat but then that when they went the
second time we didn't have any injuries
and everybody was playing where they
should play and I think there were there
were times during the year when we had
close games I've never really looked at
that that'd be interesting but when it
was all said and done and then I didn't
pay much attention to it I told me how
great year they did what I told them
they could they were capable of doing
and that really pleased me that I was
right about what I said and then you
know I never really until kind of
recently when it just hadn't happened
again so when when kids have been able
to do something put their give their
full attention to it and make it
something they wanted to do and it's
last but as long as it has that's a heck
of a thing for these kids to think about
what was plan B if you didn't become a
coach
you know that's interesting because I
went into coaching I I really enjoyed it
I don't know I mean I kind of enjoy
being a secret agent I've enjoyed
working for the government capacity
where when somehow maybe I could
contribute something worthwhile for the
USA a military career or a secret agent
so work for this guy are you too old to
do that now why do we want you to go
back to assembly hall so bad I know that
might not be on your wish list or front
burner here but why do we the fans want
closure with this coach well always the
fans and I always will you know on my
dying day I will think about how great
the fans at Indiana work and as far as
the hierarchy and Indiana University at
that time I have absolutely no respect
whatsoever for those people and that in
mind I have no interest of ever going
back to that University most of those
people aren't aren't all those people
out of there though coach I hope they're
all well I know some of them are but I
don't know I hope the rest of them go
yeah I'd like to still see you on that
court with that 76 team more isaiah's
team I don't know maybe maybe we want
closure maybe you don't need the closure
I don't know but you know like I still
hope for one day well
you staying you staying out of trouble
you're doing anything you hunting
fishing doing anything yeah when I get a
chance you know the one thing you and I
talked years and years ago hours of joy
patience it was you know the great thing
about fishing is that it's a sport it
requires a lot of intricate things but
the things that are required you don't
have to out leave on somebody you don't
have to run the floor but there a lot
that's why fishing is so good anybody
that will concentrate can can really do
it and so I've always been a great
believer in the I think how how neat
fishing is and catching fish put it back
in kind of patted on the back in the
water better fisherman or better coach
well you know to have something to do
with your wife like real good shot in
the arm for us so we've always enjoyed
that well we look forward to the
documentary tonight coach and always
great to talk to you thanks for joining
us
talking that I always thought that
beyond a lot of you contemporaries you
were actually kind of smart did we get
that on tape what coach just said about
me Paulie we got that on defense right
okay great thank you
well coach thank you I appreciate that
and I probably couldn't have played for
you though right I couldn't play defense
coach so I couldn't played for you
Thank You coach and we appreciate the
time as always thank you coach the
documentary is tonight at 9:00 Eastern
on Showtime it's the perfect in 76
documentary with coach night Bob night
courtesy of Continental Tire the Coaches
Corner
the exclusive tire the Dan Patrick show
no matter where you drive or what you
drive Continental designs tires for what
you do for more info visit Continental
Tire dot-com Continental Tire for what
you do the Dan Patrick show weekday
mornings on audience